it's tell us what's really this powerful  well I think what this reflects is well  certainly she's very very popular but I  think this also reflects apples anxiety  about its place in the new music  ecosystem Apple is coming to this in  coming to this battlefield a little bit  late  there are startup services like Spotify  that are off the ground and there's some  question whether Apple despite all of  its firepower will compete successfully  and I think what you're seeing there is  a lot of uneasiness within Apple such  that they're willing to as you say back  down in 24 hours based on a little  social media harassment from just one  artist there's a lot of flux in this in  this whole this whole segment